thank you all for being here today it's
a real honor to be around such an
amazing group of women I'd like to thank
Sharon and Kat for inviting me to come
talk to you all it's a real honor as
Jessica said I'm a co-founder of a
company called Topeka Bioworks for those
of you who have never heard of us we're
based in Boston well we're about 200
people located in the Seaport District
there and basically we design organisms
to spec and you're probably wondering
what the hell does that mean basically
the best way to sort of introduce what
we do is if you take a look at this
picture and you can see there's a lot of
Technology on this desk and does anybody
know what the most advanced piece of
technology on this desk is you're right
it's the plant all right so this believe
it or not is the most amazing piece of
technology that that any engineer can
think about right this plant can herself
or self replicate self repair it can
self-assemble and it can do all these
things that's sub nanometre precision
right these are all engineering traits
that any other engineering discipline
can only dream about
but that biology does routinely every
day right and this is why I fell in love
with biological engineering and why I
started ginkgo is because I wanted to be
able to harness this power of biology to
do great things the other fascinating
thing about biology is that it is at its
core digital right
you can program biology so every
organism whether it's you or the plant
or a bug that lives on the floor is made
up of a sqeeze GS and C's and the
sequence of those a species and C's
basically dictates the behavior of that
organism right did it just kicks what
it's capable of so if we can learn how
to program that DNA if we can learn the
right 80s G's and C's to synthesize -
right then we can program biology to do
what we want and so that's what we do
every day I gain Co is trying to figure
out how to program biology how to design
biology so this was an article that came
out a couple years ago now and why
magazine for all the Apple fanatics at
ginkgo this was the most exciting thing
ever even comparing our organism
designers at ginkgo to Johnny I write
and this is what we think about is how
to design biology how to make that
process better how'd it get smarter
about it how to make it more efficient
so you might be asking why am I here
today what am I gonna teach you all
about biological engineering
well when Kent and Sharon asked me to
speak Sharon asked me to specifically
talk about a little bit about scaling
companies so I happened to be at the YC
or the FFC conference a couple years ago
and there I talked a lot about how to
start companies and sort of my
philosophy about what what it takes to
really start a new company and so today
I'll talk a little bit about scaling
companies so one of the things that I
think Jessica already alluded to is that
two years ago I was at FFC and she
issued a challenge the group right she
gave a talk about how to not fail as a
start-up and Jessica sort of posed a
challenge for all the women in the room
she said I want to see a female founded
unicorn come out of this room right at
the time there's also obviously been a
lot of why I see unicorns but they
actually all had exclusively male
founders and so as Jessica sort of stole
my thunder I'm really excited that in
December we became another YC unicorn
and so really excited if you had asked
me 10 years ago when we started ginko
whether I would get to the spot today I
would have said hell no but you know
there you go life takes you in acts and
expected places and as a biological
engineer I'm just so excited about being
able to put these resources towards the
engineering of biology what's even
cooler about ginko becoming a unicorn is
that we are a unicorn that actually has
some shot of making a unicorn someday so
maybe I'll come back in 10 years to talk
to you about the unicorn I made
so how to scale a start-up so this is
something that I think about every day I
can't go my I'm the CEO there and so I
think a lot about how to grow and scale
the company effectively I hadn't
executes effectively and I as I thought
about what I could talk to you um today
I wanted to really focus on some advice
that has been pretty prominent in the
news recently for startups but I think
it's a little misleading actually and
that's the advice to not raise too much
money all right so there's been a lot of
headlines recently about the dangers of
raising too much money as a start-up
founder and on one hand it makes me
laugh right I think founders should be
so lucky to raise too much money for
their startup right but if you actually
dig in and look at what Sam and others
are saying what they're really talking
about is being smart about how you spend
that money so I would actually advise
raise lots of money and that's good
because as a founder if you're working
on your life's mission if a little more
money can make the difference between
success and failure then you know what
extra dilution is probably worth it but
so raise that money just don't spend it
off okay and so that's what I wanted to
talk to you today it was about the
second part of how to raise a lot of
money but not spend it all because
that's actually surprisingly hard to do
once you've raised money and that's
what's leading to these headlines that
are awarding founders not to raise too
much money so after you raise a lot of
money you can sort of have a holy cow
moment right and you're like wow these
people who are apparently smart just
handed me several million dollars to go
build my company and work on my life's
mission one are they crazy right and to
what am I going to do now all right it's
sort of the typical reaction you have
after closing around and I think the
other thing you then have is sort of an
Ono moment like how am I gonna pull this
off all right
now I have all this money and so now how
am I gonna achieve all those goals I set
out to I promised I would
and I think so you'll go through that
right and you'll say okay and you'll get
over it but sort of even more possibly
dangerously your team will go through
that too right and so they'll see all
this money any DuckTales friends from
where there are kids you know your team
will say oh hey we've raised all this
money now we can do all this new stuff
right and there's gonna be a really big
but unconscious pressure to go spend
that money on stuff right all of a
sudden all of the frugality and
scrappiness
and leanness that got you to where you
are today there's going to be a
unconscious pressure to sort of throw
that out the window right and that's
gonna manifest itself in a bunch of
different ways all right so have too
much stuff to do hire more people right
why not like we have money we can hire
more people to go do all these things on
our to-do list having a problem with a
fellow team member well go to HR we
should now be have a beefed up HR to go
take care of those interpersonal
conflicts all right
have some annoying tasks that you don't
want to do anymore oh we should hire
some administrative support and take
care of it for us right and the problem
with each of these sentiments is that in
some level they're all true right like
you raise more money you should go hire
some people to do new things right
that's why you were given the money in
the first place and yeah I like HR is
important you should invest in that and
they should be a resource for helping
people solve their their problems and
yeah you should try to operate
efficiently by outsourcing tasks that
are not important for you to do but if
you take this too far right and if your
whole team takes this too far then
that's what leads to sort of a bloat in
your company both from your headcount
size and in terms of your spend and
that's the kiss of death first startup
no matter how much money you've raised
right because you get too big you get
too bloated you spend too much then all
of a sudden the bar for how much more
you have to raise how much more you have
revenue you need to bring in to pay for
your team gets that much higher right so
if you can figure out a way to raise
money but keep the discipline keep the
scrappiness
keep the frugality then that's really
the winning combination when you're
scaling a start-up so what does it take
to make that happen well I would argue
that you need a Scrooge McDuck in your
organization right you need someone who
keeps everybody focused on what are the
key metrics for growing our business and
how do we do that in the most efficient
way possible
efficient in terms of headcount and fish
it in terms of spending right and this
is not an easy thing to do particularly
right after you've raised a bunch of
money right this is gonna be all sorts
of pressure to chose it go try to spend
your way out of problems right but
you've got to have the Scrooge in your
organization who's pushing back against
that and pushing for efficiency pushing
for scrappiness if you're a female
founder and you're taking on this cruise
mode effect roll let me tell you it's
gonna be a little bit harder for you all
right and that's because female leaders
like whether we like it or not are
subject to certain stereotypes right
like if you're taking on the Scrooge
role you know you're definitely at
personal risk for be considered the
battle ax right the tough person who's
saying no to everything
right and he's an unsympathetic I'm
caring leader right and that's just a
certain reality I wish that stereotype
didn't exist but you know it does and so
you gotta weigh that sort of personal
risk to your own reputation and to
yourself against the risk to your
organization of not having somebody
who's putting pressure on the
organization to be lean to be efficient
to retain that scrappiness right and so
that's a decision you have to make but
ultimately I think your your startup
success is going to hinge on whether or
not you have this pressure being applied
right because the more efficient you can
be the longer your runway is the more
optionality you're gonna have as you go
forward with your startup so your goal
is really to try to scale your startup
scale your revenues scale your customer
base whatever metric by which you
measure commercial success grow it
without growing your headcount and your
spend too much
and only you can really define like what
too much is but in general that's what
you're trying to do you're trying to
decouple your growth in your commercial
success from your growth in your spend
and your head count if you can crack
this nut this is a huge competitive
advantage no matter how much you raise
no matter what this is can be huge for
your team and the reason for that is
that all sorts of problems scale with a
number of people you have in your
organization right so recruiting becomes
harder right you have more people it's
harder to recruit top talent people when
you have to hire twice as many people as
you might otherwise have to similarly
you know interpersonal problems well
they scale with N squared so if you have
n people in your in your organization
you have N squared possibilities for
conflict right and a million different
things get harder and harder as your
organization grows and so if you can
again grow your business by whatever
metrics are important revenue customers
eyeballs whatever number of GMOs you can
produce then then you just had a huge
huge advantage relative to others and
you're building an inherently stronger
longer-term business so how do you scale
without actually scaling all right
that's a fundamental challenge and let
me tell you it's not easy it's one that
I've been working on for several years
now and I won't pretend like I've
totally cracked this nut but it's a
worthy problem to work on as you're
growing your company the best thing I
figured out so far is based on a
conversation I had with Ali rouhani a
couple years ago now Ali is a YC partner
and he's in charge of the YC growth
program and I went and sat down with Ali
and I think this was probably just after
we raised her seriously or something and
you know I was like hey you know what
advice do you have for me like as we're
trying to grow our company and whatnot
and Ali told me about hit this concept
of mission to metrics he actually later
wrote up a blog post on
um so I'd encourage you to go read this
if you haven't already but all you
basically said that as a leader of a
company your job is to map out the
mission to metrics for your organization
right so what's your mission what what
is your organization all about right
this is your purpose for your
organization you probably should already
have this on the day you start all right
so I can't go our mission is to make
biology easier to engineer that was the
first thing we figured out before we
even had a name for the company we
figured out our mission statement right
your your strategy that's really what
your commercial strategy right how are
you gonna make money how are you gonna
get people to pay you for what you want
to do how are you gonna be a sustainable
company in order to deliver on your
mission right and so that obviously
takes a ton of that right and only you
can figure it out and honestly your
commercial strategy might change several
times over the course of growing your
company even as you're in growth stage
and that's okay that's totally fine we
still need to have a hypothesis about
what your commercial strategy is and
then finally based on them what that
strategy is you needed to find your
metrics how are you gonna quantitatively
measure whether you're succeeding or
failing at your strategy all right this
is hard all right this is not a trivial
thing this is something that like even I
can go we continuously work on a refine
over time right but if you can define
that mission to strategy to metrics and
even more importantly if you can explain
it to the entire team right make sure
that everybody at your company
understands this then they can connect
what they do every day to the metrics of
the organization to the commercial
strategy to the mission of the
organization it's a hugely powerful
aligning force for any startup and so I
would argue I would add one thing to
what Ali said right so yes how do you
scale without scaling define your
mission to metrics that's huge it's
gonna take a lot of work expect it to
that it might take months or years for
you to figure out but try to figure it
out and then I would say that
also make sure that your metrics include
one other thing which is that at least
one of your metrics should be focused on
efficiency right so instead of a total
output you know is it output per person
is it you know dollars of revenue per
salesperson whatever your efficiency
metric is make sure that's included as
one of your metrics because if your opt
if you force your team to optimize on
efficiency then you're forcing them to
think about what goes in that
denominator right how many people does
it take how many dollars does it take to
achieve your goals and so I think this
is a nice way to sort of encode a value
system around efficiency in your
organization is by defining metrics
around efficiency as part of your
overall mission the metrics and then
finally as I said before you need the
Scrooge who's going to be pushing that
message across the organization day in
and day out again it's not an easy job I
know cuz I have it I can go but I think
it's the one that's hugely important for
the long-term health in the success of
your organization and so this is what
we've been doing it can go over the past
few years you know we figured out our
mission 10 years ago it's to make
biology easy to engineer roughly
speaking our strategy in a nutshell is
to try to aggregate genetic engineering
R&D it can go and our metric is thinking
about just how much genetic engineering
can we do per person in kinko
so driving mad efficiency as much as
possible is incredibly important to our
strategy every day so with that again
I'd like to thank all of you for being
here today and thanks to Sharon and Kat
for the invitation
you
you